et sans doute pas inconnu elle est l'un
des visages de ce qu'on appelle la
génération internet la chanteuse yelle
est en tournée dans toute l'europe
depuis septembre dernier sa musique
électro-pop rencontre un succès énorme
olivier les noy's à et dominique bonnet
ont rencontré la jeune femme à barcelone
voici le reportage
elle joue les divas mais ne se prend pas
au sérieux
en concert ce soir là en espagne il est
elle devenue score grâce à ce titre une
réponse on rappeur 6,6
sopo
apparemment tout l'air
cette chanson yale la dépense fin 2005
sur internet
les connexions explose ou alors
s'accélère une maison de disques
flairent le bon filon et l 24 ans
originaire de saint brieuc devient un
phénomène international
ma musique ne ressemble vraiment mon les
brésiliens elle est très coloré
brésilien italiens espagnols les
journalistes se l'arrachent superman
marqueterie au plafond mais j'ai même
pas eu le temps de l'apprécier
photo
une séance photos pour un magazine
branché même organisé ici le look
travaillé au millimètre est aussi
important que la musique vient des
chanteurs qui shampoing et puis il ya
ceux qui ont une image très mode y
allons pas partie il est l'égérie de la
mode adorent et dans les cours d'école
on peut toucher des générations
différentes ça montre aussi une
ouverture et que voilà on peut écrire
des textes qui au départ s'adresse à des
gens de 25 30 ans et plus qui finalement
ma tous des les plus jeunes et puis
aussi des plus vieux
des concerts s'était fait un peu partout
en europe une tournée prévue à la
rentrée en amérique du sud
les garçons dont à bien se tenir
avant de refermer ce journal